let's talk about hellhounds if Archie
here ever stops being a fairly decent
guard cockatiel I think I'll need a
replacement and I'm going hellhound
they're bred for it but which one the
obvious choice might be Cerberus Hades
three-headed OG hellhound that won't
even let a kidnapped goddess back from
the dead but he can't below to sleep
with music and with three mouths to feed
I know Arch obvious negatives oh maybe
Le shende Boule that hellhound wanted
the Cliffs of boulay dragging its chain
behind it and that sound alone scares
off Intruders and if not lishen can
chase high speed circles around them you
know what never mind I'm going poodle I
mean just look at Fifi from Goosebumps